بدأ البرلمان الإيطالي هذا الأسبوع عملية
انتخاب الرئيس الثالث عشر للبلاد ، ولا
يشمل الانتخاب عامة الجمهور بشكل مباشر حيث
أنه تم إجراؤه بين 630 عضوًا في
البرلمان ، وتم استدعاء 320 عضوًا في مجلس الشيوخ و 58 نائباً إقليمياً
إلى
مجلس النواب حيث أدلوا.
تصويتهم في السر وعندما
يتم ذلك ، يقرأ المتحدث باسم الغرفة
الاسم المكتوب على كل ورقة اقتراع ،
أي اسم يحتاج إلى أغلبية الثلثين
ليتم انتخابه في
الجولات الثلاث الأولى من التصويت بعد أن
تكون هناك حاجة إلى أغلبية بسيطة  تستمر الجلسة
حتى يتم انتخاب شخص ما ، وقد
يستغرق ذلك أيامًا ، والهدف هو انتخاب
رئيس دولة جديد قبل الثالث من
فبراير عندما تنتهي ولاية الرئيس الحالي
سيرجيو ماتاريلا ، ومن
ثم لا يتعين عليك أن تكون رئيسًا.
يجب اعتبار
السياسي للدور الذي يجب أن يتجاوز
عمره 50 عامًا يجب أن يحمل الجنسية الإيطالية
وأن يكون مسجلاً للتصويت وليس ممنوعًا قانونيًا
من توليه  هذا هو السبب وراء
ظهور شخصيات عامة مثل الممثلة
صوفيا لورين في الماضي كمنافسين محتملين
خلال عملية التصويت ،
والآن يُنظر إلى دور الرئيس الذي تم إنجازه
على مدى فترة سبع سنوات في كثير من الأحيان على أنه
الرؤساء الشرفيون هم
الرئيس الرسمي للدولة ولكن ليس رئيس الدولة.
السلطة التنفيذية التي ستكون رئيسًا للوزراء ،
لكن الرؤساء يصرحون
بمشاريع القوانين البرلمانية ويعينون
رؤساء وزراء جددًا وأعضاء مجلس الوزراء ،
ويمكنهم أيضًا رفض تعيينهم وهم
يمارسون هذه الحقوق على سبيل المثال
بعد فترة وجيزة من الانتخابات العامة 2018 ،
رفض الرئيس الحالي سيرجيو ماتاريلا تعيين رئيس وزراء جديد.  وزير المالية المتشكك في الاتحاد الأوروبي
على الرغم من الموافقة على الترشيح من
قبل غالبية نواب البرلمان
خلال أزمة سياسية ،
يمكن للرئيس أن يكلف شخصًا بمهمة تشكيل
حكومة جديدة في عام 2021 ،
استدعى ماتاريلا الرئيس السابق
للبنك المركزي الأوروبي ماريو دراغي
وطلب منه تشكيل حكومة جديدة  التي من
شأنها أن تقود إيطاليا خلال الأزمة المالية
التي سببتها ر  إن جائحة الفيروس التاجي والأزمة السياسية التي نشأت عندما استقال رئيس الوزراء السابق جوزيبي كونتي بسبب انهيار حكومته ، لم يتم ترشيح المتنافسين رسميًا على الرئاسة ، مما دفع بعض المعلقين إلى مقارنتها بمجلس بابوي مع مرشح محتمل لم يحكم نفسه. تم الإشادة برئيس الوزراء ماريو دراغي على قدرته على إنقاذ اليورو خلال أزمة منطقة اليورو عام 2012 ، وهو معروف شعبياً باسم سوبر ماريو ، لكن أن يصبح دراغي رئيساً يعني ترك مقعد رئيس الوزراء شاغراً وربما دفع البلاد إلى أزمة سياسية جديدة